nintendo showed off a big list of  third-party partners when it revealed  the switch including take to the parent  company behind grand theft auto and red  dead take to president carl sled off  recently commented on the console at the  credit suisse technology media and  telecom conference saying his company  has a positive outlook on the console he  stated with any new hardware there is  always an element of wait and see we're  very intrigued and excited about it the  Nintendo folks I think are making a  great effort to reach out to third-party  developers which i think is fantastic  other big companies like EA Activision  and Ubisoft have also confirmed  partnerships with Nintendo but no  specific games just yet we'll hear more  about the switches launch lineup and  maybe more from those companies during  then tendo's presentation on january 12  to keep up with all the latest from all  of these publishers you're already in  the right place  you